[Musique]
les décorations de noël ne sont pas
encore remises dans les cartons mais
déjà tous les châteaux de la loire qui
ont investi la magie de noël sont
satisfaits de l'opération au château de
langeais c'est un bilan très positif qui
ressort de cette période de fêtes une
fréquentation qui a augmenté de plus de
plus de 30 % sur le mois de décembre
donc c'est quand même pas négligeable
cette année et c'est la fin de
l'opération qui a débuté il ya
maintenant un mois donc on va tout est
monté au moyen-âge noël et la période du
solstice d'hiver où les nuits sont les
plus longues et cette période annonce
aussi le retour des beaux jours et du
soleil donc déjà au moyen-âge noël était
liée à la lumière si c'était une fête de
la lumière en revisitant l'époque
médiévale et renaissance sur le thème de
noël de ses lumières le château de
langeais offert un ravissement
supplémentaire à tous ses visiteurs
c'était une très bonne idée ça donne une
une scénographie ça donne une de la
lumière de la vie et je me suis demandé
mais commencé quand c'est pas noël c'est
le fait de voir ses châteaux habituel
sous un autre angle avec une déco de
noël ça les met en valeur un peu
différemment go cette opération noël au
pays des châteaux s'adresse aussi aux
familles qui se réunissent en touraine
pour cette période de fêtes une
clientèle familiale et locale qui
allonge la saison touristique 5 août
puisqu'il faut faire toutes ces
décorations c'est un coût est également
en termes de personnel puisque on est
obligé d'embaucher pour accueillir nos
visiteurs qui sont beaucoup plus
nombreux qu en scène passe période
d'habitude mais ça reste une une
opération qui permet de faire parler
nous qui fait venir plus de monde donc
ça s'équilibre l'opération noël au pays
des châteaux a pris fin ce dimanche les
décorations sont rangés en attendant le
printemps et le départ de la saison
touristique habituel